und sie hat mir dazu geschrieben haye
allerdings video sehen kannst ist mein
zeugnis nicht so gut ich werde dieses
jahr leider nicht versetzt aber
wahrscheinlich wechsel dich jetzt auch
die realschule ich meine das ist ja der
widerspruch in sich lia hat in
deutschland 3 und ihr zurück wenn ich
mal schuljahr richtig schreiben weil ich
einen schönen natur brise man hat die
blätter im wind rauschen und die sonne
scheint aber nicht hier
hey leute was geht ab wir bekommen bei
einem neuen video ja leute ich hoffe
natürlich euch gesucht ich bin heute mal
draußen einfach weil ich es in meinem
zimmer zur wahl finde und draußen ist so
ein schönes wetter leider hört man
natürlich ein bisschen im hintergrund
die autos die lang fahre man hört auch
diese blätter rauschen aber ich hoffe
ihr versteht mich trotzdem gut ja heute
habt ihr wahrscheinlich am titel schon
gelesen
gegen ihn ist das doch ganz schön laut
und ich habe es natürlich auch gestern
angekündigt es gibt einen park von neun
zeugen ja wir haben einen deutschland
bundesländer wie niedersachsen oder
rheinland-pfalz glaube ich die haben
schon ferien in nrw die schüler noch
nicht aber ich habe trotzdem gestern
schon eine menge zeugnisse bekommen ich
hab ich ja gesagt wenn euer zeugnis
irgendwie was besonderes ist entweder
besonders schlecht oder besonders gut
schickt mir das gerne einfach zu und ich
schaue mal an das gilt natürlich immer
noch also wenn ihr jetzt eure zeugnis
bekommt ist auf jeden fall über alte was
geht ab auf der straße plötzlich von der
trecker lang dann schickten das gerne
auf instagram zu und wenn ihr glück habt
ihr im video so ich habe für den
heutigen part also den ersten part für
die zeugnisse zweites halbjahr 2017 2018
80 herausgesucht die schauen wir uns
jetzt zusammen an die sind wirklich echt
krass also eigentlich will ich mal
schätzen und die krassesten die ich bis
jetzt drin hatte und ich will gar nicht
lange lagern wir fangen sofort mal an
mit einem zeugnis was mir eine etwas
ältere personen geschickter und zwar der
rheiner rainer hat 2005 und 2006 den
abschluss gemacht also das ist jetzt
kein zeugnis was ich auf den aktuellen
zeitraum beziehen aber es trotzdem
lustig und zwar ist das zeugnis vom
rheiner so wir schauen uns erst mal den
text an
rainer ist ein ruhiger schüler dem
unterrichtsgeschehen folgt er zunächst
interessiert und versuchte sich mit
eigenen bisweilen durchdachten beiträgen
zu beteiligen mit seinen
klassenkameraden kam es nun seltener zu
konflikten in die klassengemeinschaft
war er
noch nicht vollständig integrierte
schriftliche arbeiten erledigte rainer
zumeist zuverlässig jedoch nur selten
ordentlich sein häufiges fehlen
beeinträchtige seine leistung in allen
fächern im fahrsport konnte rainer
aufgrund von häufigen unentschuldigten
fernbleiben keine leistungserhöhung
stattfinden ja also der eine hat mir das
zeugnis geschickt mit einer botschaft
auch wenn man sich das anschaut ist
jetzt natürlich nicht das gelbe vom ei
ja das kann man ganz offen und ehrlich
sagen aber es ist auch nicht so
unterirdisch schlecht bis halt auf sport
ungenügend weil einer nicht da war so
und jetzt ganz wichtig erst mit
dazugeschrieben hey hier mein zeugnis
von damals war dann auch ziemlich faul
deswegen auch sonderschule und so hab so
das muss ich noch dazu sagen das sagen
ist vom sonderpädagogischen
förderzentrum also halt eine
sonderschule so und er hat mir dazu
geschrieben habe hier mein zeugnis von
damals war dann auch ziemlich faul
deswegen auch sonderschule und so habe
aber inzwischen die kurve gekriegt und
bin erfolgreicher internet unternehmer
so wir machen weiter mit dem nächsten
zeugnis und das kommt von liga durch
brands hier mal kurz ein lea geht in die
8 d und zwar haben hier wirklich ein
sehr besonderes zeugnis und wäre ich der
direktor von lias ude
da würde ich mich wirklich schämen sich
mit ganz normales zeugnis keine ahnung
schnitt von 2,5 würde ich mal schätzen
entspricht alles den erwartungen hier
hat in deutschen 3 und dann schreibt die
schule oben links in die ecke schuljahr
ohne h ich meine das ist ja der
widerspruch in sich lia hat in
deutschland 3 und ihrer schule könne
nicht mal schuljahr richtig schreiben
also die war direkter oder wer auch
immer dieses zeugnis ausgestellt hat sie
sollten sich schämen so leute wir machen
weiter mit dem ist das mikrofon
überhaupt an das habe ich gerade ein
schock bekommt mit dem allerbesten
zeugnissen nicht mit dem zweitbesten
zeug das was mir ein gesendet wurde ich
hab es leider keinen plan mehr wie die
person hieß aber es ist das hier und
zwar ist es ein zeugnis ich weiß nicht
welche klasse wir haben hier rallye 1
deutsch und englisch französisch 1
geschichte 1 geografie 1 politik 1 und
den rest auch eins da muss ich jetzt mal
knallhart sagen so eine aussage wie hier
drauf steht nicht ausreichende leistung
können die versetzung gefährden entfällt
nicht verstehen ich meine wir sonst
schnitt hat kommt natürlich nicht weiter
da hilft auch die einzige italienische
nichts also einen bomben schnitt
das immer so krass weil wir hatten auch
so leute sie hatten über eine 10
normalerweise sind diese leute ja dann
meistens total unsportlich hatten sport
aber auch er einst einfach weil sie dem
lehrer kuchen mitgebracht haben oder so
wenn ihr diese leute kennt das man habe
nach oben das nächste zeugen es wurde
mir eingesendet vom tarik und tarik
hatten wirklich lustiges zeugnis oder
was ist lustig also wir haben ja auch
ein eigentlich ziemlich guten schnitt
ich würde mal so eine ahnung 18 tippen
das lässt sich jetzt nur wenn man jetzt
mal genauer schaut teilnahme an
folgenden arbeitsgemeinschaften jugend
forscht den müll kann ich auch und so
weiter und tarek dazu geschrieben hier
ist mein zeugnis also es ist so erstens
mein zeugnis relativ gut ja das habe ich
schon gesagt zweitens stehen bei mir ags
an denen ich teilgenommen habe und in
der ein jugend forsch war aber nie da
weil ich immer in der falschen ag war
und das ist mir nie aufgefallen ich war
eineinhalb jahre in der falschen ag
trotzdem steht auf tages zeugnis er hat
daran teilgenommen
da sieht man mal wie ernst ags von der
schule behandelt werden ich habe sowieso
nie die leute verstanden die noch
zusätzlich hingegen welcher ags gegangen
sind ich meine wenn du schon jeden tag
acht stunden in der schule sitzt so ist
es zumindest ab der zehnten klasse bei
mir gewesen habe ich doch kein bock nach
diesen acht stunden auf drei stunden ag
zu machen
so macht man weiter mit dem zeugnis
keine ahnung ob ich das benutzen darf
aber ich kenne sie ja schön dass gehört
meiner freundin und sie musste noch
nicht mal wiederholen
sie ist damit einverstanden also nette
freundin hast auf jeden fall so nach dem
motto ja die ist verfolgt schlecht aber
sie muss ja nicht mal wiederholen
und wenn man sich das ganze hier
anschaut ja ja ja eh deutsch fünf
englisch 5 gesellschaftslehre vier
religion 5 das verstehe ich auch nicht
die leute die in religion s5 haben ich
meine da gibt es ja nicht mal wirklich
ein richtig oder falsch du musst nur
einfach deine meinung mal kurz sagen
okay das sehe ich auch so oder nicht es
sei denn du sollst sagen wann
weihnachten ist das ist was anderes aber
was religion angela basiert ja viel auch
auf dem eigenen glauben und auf der
eigenen meinung genauso wie in
philosophie und leute die dame 5 haben
das kann ich nicht verstehen hatte vier
naturwissenschaften fünf kunst vier
musik 56 versäumte unterricht schon 15
also
das ist jetzt für mich ein rätsel das
zeugnis alters ist ja schon echt oder es
ist wirklich hart ihr könnt mir gern mal
schreiben wenn man im sport immer da ist
der lehrer kann jedoch keine 6 geben
oder interpretiere ich da jetzt
irgendwas falsch
vor allem das ist auch noch die ich
glaube siebte klasse also hier deine 6
zu verteilen das ist ja echt richtig
hart und da tut mir das mädchen auf
jeden fall ein bisschen leid also kopf
hoch das leben geht weiter und nächste
schuljahr wird es was und schickt mir
dann gerne mal zu blutig verbessert als
aber ich glaub an dich um ehrlich zu
sein freue ich mich auch wie man hier
wird versetzt werden kann weil 55 55 55
56 so leute wir machen weiter ich habe
mir gerade schon gesagt das war das
zweitbeste zeug das was ich eben gezeigt
habe und jetzt kommt's mir wirklich zum
besten eignet hallo und zwar hat mir das
so ein abitur coach geschickt der glaube
ich selber gar nicht abitur macht
sondern das ist das beste zeugnis
vermutlich was er jemals bekommen hat
oder gesehen hat und zwar ist es ja dann
irgendwann so dass man nicht mehr
einfach nur eins zwei drei vier oder
fünf oder auch sechs bekommt sondern man
kriegt punkte von eins bis 15 15 ist nur
eins plus eins ist eine sechs- oder so
irgendwie so dann ist es halt auch
möglich wenn durchschnitt zu erreichen
der unter 1 liegt das heißt man kann ich
glaube bis zu 0,7 ich glaube 0 794 ist
das allerbeste was man erreichen kann dh
man hat in jedem fach eine eins plus und
zwar mir ein abiturzeugnis erreichte
punkte den fächern 472 blablabla
abiturprüfungen schriftlich deutsch eins
plus eins plus
ich schätze mal jetzt geografie 1 -
englisch 1 psp es keine ahnung was ist
es auch einsplus also 15 punkte ist halt
eine 1+ das einzige was nicht einflusses
ist geografie durchschnittsnote 1,0 und
ersten jetzt hier dazu geschrieben sie
hat einfach in den fünf
abschlussprüfungen 4 x 15 punkte und
einmal 13 punkte
das ist umgerechnet in den notenschnitt
07940 abi prüfungen
ach so als der gesamtdurchschnitt des 10
in den abi prüfung aber 0,7 94
und sowas gibt es jetzt wirklich nicht
so ob ich meinen fast überall eine eins
plus zu erreichen
das ist er nicht auch nicht verstehen
ich war auch immer so zum beispiel in
deutsch hatte ich meistens so in den
analysen 3 und ich fand meine analyse
wirklich gut ich hätte sich auf keinen
fall besser schreiben können und dann
kommen so mädchen um die ecke mit einer
1 und man denkt sich wie aber das ist
dann halt so dass man mit leben ich
fange hier im schatten schon an zu
schwitzen so dann kommen jetzt auch
schon zum letzten zeugnis und zwar hat
mir das auch ein mädchen zuschickt aus
der siebten klasse die leider also wir
gucken uns erst mal das zeugnis an der
mir 1 geschichte eine 5 in französisch
nur fünf in mathe mit 55 in physik mit 5
und der rest ist so mittelmäßig und sie
hat mir dazu geschrieben hey alex video
sehen kannst ist mein zeugnis nicht so
gut ich werde dieses jahr leider nicht
versetzt aber wahrscheinlich wechsel
dich jetzt auf die realschule oder wenn
man sich das ganze so anschaut ist es
leider so entweder sie legt eine kleine
ehrenrunde ein oder sie geht halt auf
die realschule
weil ich gar nicht weiß ob man dann
einfach auf der reaktion der achten
klasse weitermachen kann ich glaube
nämlich nicht ist natürlich immer hart
zu wiederholen wobei du eigentlich auch
froh sein kann ich meine ich habe zum
beispiel g8 gemacht na warte mal das
heißt ich habe zwölf jahre nur für meine
navi gebraucht und am ende war es schon
wirklich viel und man ist doch viel in
der schule deswegen g9 also 13 jahre
schule finde ich viel besser
ich meine wenn man dann zum teil schon
mit 17 jahren sein abitur hat das ist
echt früh ich bin 18 19 ist okay das
war's mit dem video das gerne daumen
nach oben dafür den nächsten part wie
gesagt schickt mir gerne eure zeugnisse
zu über instagram und ich wünsche euch
ein traumhaftes wochenende genießt das
wetter genießen ferien falls ich hab wir
sehen uns zu sonntag wieder gibt es
neues cooles video und hat rein
abonniert nicht vergessen